the concept of washington's revolving
door goes like this administration
officials from both parties often leave
office and step into lucrative positions
often in industries they used to lead or
regulate and a new study from columbia
university's brown institute for media
innovation muckrock and forbes found
that the potential earnings for these
arrangements can be massive
for years we know from magnetic thoughts
that politicians can make a lot of money
by going through the revolving door
but nobody knows how much
we at the brown institute at columbia
university tracked more than 1100
officials in the buying administration
among them we found 151 who qualified as
revolving door officials
that is they left the government in the
final days of the obama administration
worked for the private sector and then
returned undivided for 77 of these
officials were able to obtain their
before and after financial disclosures
and we found a 270 percent increase in
the reported minimum assets
in comparison
u.s household assets increased 38
from 2017 to 2021 and the s p 500 went
up 70 over the same period
so we can see these officials made a lot
more money than average amount
there are three major ways people made
money going through the revolving door
the first is to join a big company and
earn a big salary
i consider defense secretary loy austin
after he retired as four-star general in
2016
austin joined the boards of race and
a major military contractor new core
corporation one of the biggest steel
producers in the u.s antenna healthcare
he made more than one billion dollars in
cash and 2 million dollars in equities
the second way for those who don't work
directly for a big company is to join a
law firm or lobbying for example beth
george a lawyer in the defense and
justice departments under obama headed
to a silicon valley law firm where she
made 1.8 million dollars in 2020 working
for companies such as google twitter and
stamp
the third way is to start your own shop
then deputy secretary of state anthony
blinken co-founded a strategic
consulting firm called red exact
advisors
where he had clients such as fedex
blackstone and uber three years later as
secretary of state he listed 1.2 million
dollars of guaranteed payments and
distributions from west exec
and over 1.5 million dollars of
investments connected to his firm he's
now worth an estimated 10 million
dollars
representatives from the small business
administration office of the director of
national intelligence the white house
and state department said in statements
that their employees face routine and
stringent ethic requirements while in
office
on the day he became president joe biden
issued an executive order that banned
officials from working on some issues
like regulations and contracts that are
directly related to their former
employers and clients the ban however
only applies to cases where a personal
service has been provided to the company
in question which also has to be a named
party in the policy discussion
in reality much of what a corporation
wants from the government is more
abstract for example broad tax relief
for general trade policy
what we found most interesting
is both republicans and democrats claim
to hate this one
however members from both parties
benefit from it and we picked these
obama abiding officials not because we
thought one party is worse than the
other rather this is the only data
currently available to us
and we wanted to shed light
on this important issue of government
ethics in washington
[Music]
you